[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ce set 8
journal du jeudi 7 mars sur tv 78 tout
de suite les titres de cette édition 80
surveillants pénitentiaires devant la
maison d'arrêt de bois d'arcy ce matin
une mobilisation de soutien suite aux
agressions de gardiens de prison cette
semaine à poissy et condé sur sarthe
c'est les agents demandent notamment
davantage de contrôles lors des parloirs
et des détenus les formations politiques
en campagne pour les élections
européennes programmé le 26 mai prochain
hier la france un sou miss tenait une
réunion publique à saint cyr l'école est
l'un des candidats du parti pour le
scrutin est venu échanger avec les
participants
enfin vous connaissiez peut-être le
festivent impro voici désormais sa
version junior la première édition se
tient demain et samedi aux clayes sous
bois et à plaisir sur scène des jeunes
de 3 troupe d'improvisation ils viennent
de belgique de france ou encore du
québec et nous en parlons avec nos
invités et nous présenterons également
sur ce plateau une conférence sur la
maladie de lyme qui se tient le jeudi à
14 mars prochain a lu vs qu l'actualité
du jour donc cette mobilisation des
surveillants pénitentiaires et de bois
d'arcy ils étaient 80 environ à se
rassembler tôt dans la matinée devant la
maison d'arrêt une ak une action en
soutien aux gardiens de prisons agressé
cette semaine 2 hier à la maison
centrale de poissy mardi un détenu a
radicalisé a blessé deux agents
également avec un couteau en céramique
introduit par sa compagne est lors d'une
visite à la prison de condé sur sarthe
dans l'ordre l'individu s'était ensuite
retranché à bois d'arcy ce matin le
mouvement a duré jusqu'à 11 heures et
les manifestants demandent une
reclassification des établissements mais
aussi plus de contrôles lors des visites
des proches avec palpation et scanners
corporels les propos sont recueillis par
mélanie poker
malheureusement c'est le quotidien des
surveillants pénitentiaires il se passe
pas une journée sans qu'ils aient au
moins une agression par établissement
donc
jeje g et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
les personnels se mobilisent afin
d'alerter l'opinion publique est
également notre ministre afin de réagir
par rapport à ça j'ai repris les détenus
comment les gérer il ya 20 ans déjà
d'une part et d'autre part tant qu'on
n'a pas des moyens humains et matériels
qui sera de plus en plus difficile de
gérer la population pénale tout en
sachant que nos établissements ne sont
pas adaptés aux différents profils que
nous avons donc tant qu'il n'y a pas une
reclassification des établissements on
aura toujours ces mêmes difficultés
une réunion publique à saint cyr l'école
organisé par le mouvement de la france
insoumise des yvelines hier mercredi une
soirée dans le cadre de la campagne pour
les élections européennes avec en invité
thomas guénolé candidat du parti pour ce
scrutin prévu le 26 mai prochain le
reportage de nicolas landry l'union
européenne et l anti sociale la phrase
et interrogative mais elle sous-entend
l'affirmatif c'est la thématique de la
réunion publique organisée par la france
insoumise des yvelines candidats pour
les élections européennes thomas guénolé
est venu partager sa vision de l'union
européenne avec plusieurs objectifs
1 la transition écologique totale de
l'économie
2 un modèle social européen qui soit le
modèle le plus exigeant disponibles
qu'on puisse imaginer par exemple avec
un smic européen qui soit au même niveau
dans toute l'europe et c'est préserver
les droits fondamentaux et assurer la
paix dans le monde des transformations
de l'union européenne vu aussi par les
militants yvelinois union européenne qui
permette de tirer
de tirer les conditions sociales vers le
haut qui arrêtent de tirer les
conditions écologiques vers le haut qui
permet de contenir et des conditions
démocratiques vers le haut on rêve d'une
europe qui soit vraiment démocratique et
non pas une démocrature qui soit une
europe ouverte également mais justement
je suis là aussi pour ça ce soir parce
que j'avoue qu'on a toujours du mal à
savoir quand on regarde les médias on a
l'impression que
l'union européenne ses supérieurs n'ont
même pas qu'il ya plein de choses qui
vont pas d'autres actions sont prévues
dans le cadre des élections européennes
le 4 avril prochain un van france
insoumise fera escale aux mureaux et ali
mais aujourd'hui le mouvement revendique
près de 200 militants sur le bassin
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines là
demain vendredi c'est la journée
internationale des droits des femmes
l'occasion de faire le bilan sur la
situation des femmes en france et dans
le monde le sais tu te lèves d'eau de
vendredi sera d'ailleurs en grande
partie consacré à ce rendez-vous
reportages sur des femmes entrepreneuses
inauguration de l'antenne du centre
d'information sur les droits des femmes
et des familles à rambouillet et pour
commenter ces actualités manon varaldo
recevra la sénatrice l ère des yvelines
martha de sidrac première invitée avec
moi en plateau marie-josée taylor
bonsoir bonsoir êtes la responsable de
fondation pour le rotary club montfort
l'amaury houdan alors vous organisé
jeudi à 14 mars à 19h une conférence sur
la maladie de lyme ça se passe dans l'un
des amphithéâtres de l'université
versailles saint quentin sur le campus
de guyancourt cette conférence sera
animée par le professeur christian
perronne alors avant d'en parler de
présenter cette conférence quelques mots
de présentation sur le retravailler le
rotary club c'est un réseau mondial quel
est son but elle les objectifs du rotary
c'est de développer l'éducation dans le
monde de régler les problèmes de l'eau
dans les pays en voie de développement
est aussi de lutter contre les maladies
comme la polio contre les maladies du
cerveau
la maladie lime et beaucoup d'autres
maladies parce que bon il y en a
malheureusement beaucoup alors il ya
plusieurs clubs
au travers de ce retard y est notamment
cette antenne à montfort l'amaury et et
houdan c'est une antenne active il ya
beaucoup de d'événements qui sont
organisées par cette année nous
organisons beaucoup d'événements dans
cette conférence nous avons organisé un
tournoi de golf au moins de septembre
octobre au golf la colline pour
recueillir des fonds pour nos actions et
puis nous aurons aussi la fête des
plantes le 6 et 7 avril
montfort l'amaury ou en vendée plantes
où on accueille des exposants et ça nous
permet de recueillir des fonds pour
faire nos actions voulait dit un intérêt
particulier sur le thème de la santé là
c'est un événement consacré à la maladie
de lyme une pathologie liée à la piqûre
d'une tique infectée
quels sont les symptômes de cette
maladie et quelles conséquences sur sur
le corps humain mais en fait les
symptômes ils peuvent être diverses a
peut être des inflammations très forte
des membres ça peut être une fatigue
chronique qui se développe et les
personnes n'ont plus envie de se lever
le matin
ça peut être des problèmes au niveau du
cerveau les personnes n'arrive plus à
parler voilà il ya différents types de
symptômes qui peuvent être significatif
de cette maladie est bon cette maladie
quand elle devient chronique elle est
dégénérative et voilà c'est très
embêtant
bon ce qu'il ya c'est qu'il faut que
cette maladie soit diagnostiquée très
rapidement aujourd'hui en france
malheureusement les tests ne sont pas
toujours fiables ce qui fait qu'il ya
beaucoup de malades en errance et qui ne
savent pas toujours de quelle maladie
sont atteints donc ils vont de service
en service
il faut faire des examens qui coûte très
cher la sécurité sociale puisqu'il ya
qu'aujourd'hui elle n'est pas traitée de
manière convenable en france où l'air
lorsque vous allez chez un médecin qui
ne connaît pas bien cette maladie bah
vous n'êtes pas traitée pour cette
pathologie on va vous traiter pour des
pathologies que vous n'avez pas parce
que vous avez des symptômes d'autres
maladies mais bon si envoûtera traite
pour ces maladies on va pas vous guérir
c'est pour ça que vous organisez une
conférence sur ce thème c'est pour la
faire connaître davantage cette cette
maladie tout à fait tout à fait et dire
qu'aujourd'hui la recherche avance que
nous avons justement des personnes comme
le professeur peron qui à travers le
guide de l'hôpital
raymond poincaré de garches font des
recherches et permettre de trouver des
traitements et développer des tests
fiables
le professeur peron qui animera cette
conférence d'ailleurs au delà de ce but
informatif aussi un objectif de soutenir
la recherche puisque les fonds récoltés
grâce à cette conférence serviront à
financer la recherche à l'hôpital
universitaire de garches rue raymond
poincaré toute assez bon nous allons
recueillir des fonds en plus notre
district va abonder à hauteur de 50% des
fonds que nous allons verser aux
professeurs peron de manière ce que nous
pêchions lui donner une somme
significative pour continuer ses
recherches
un tarif de 20 euros avec d'ailleurs une
collation à qui est comprise pour cette
conférence qui est-il christian perronne
c'est le chef des deux du service des
maladies infectieuses à l'hôpital
poincaré de garches et les spécialiser
dans cette maladie de lyme il est en
tout cas écrit sur le sujet il a écrit
un ouvrage qui s'appelle la vérité sur
la maladie glam qu'il dédicacera
justement à l'occasion de cette
conférence et qui traitent justement de
qui nous éclaire sur cette fameuse malle
ajiq beaucoup de personnes connaissent
mais qui est pas si connu que ça du
grand public
est ce que vous espérez avec eux cette
conférence qu'on en parle davantage de
certains parlent d'un otage et puis que
les gens puissent se traiter plus
efficacement là parce qu'ils savent que
la maladie de lyme existent et qu'ils
peuvent y penser parce que mon mari
lorsqu'il a été atteinte par la maladie
de lyme
j'ai été très ému ni je me suis pas
rendu compte qu'il avait cette maladie
est heureusement mon médecin qui était
homéopathe m'a dit ça doit être la
maladie de lyme les tests ont été
positifs il a pu être traitée très
rapidement vous avez ressenti à l'époque
c'est un sentiment d'abandon c'est ça
c'est il ya un abandon des malades un
petit peu oui oui un petit peu
il faut tomber sur le bon médecin qui va
faire le bon diagnostic en question
pratique pour y participent à cette
conférence il faut s'inscrire à l'avancé
il vaut mieux s'inscrire à la vente sur
le site rotary montfort l'amour est
dedans
actuellement voilà et donc nous avons
encore des places merci à marie josée
taylor conférence sur la maladie de lyme
jeudi 14 mars à 19h a lu vs cul sur le
campus de guyancourt et toutes les
informations je le rappelle sont à
retrouver sur votre site internet le
site du rotary club de montfort l'amaury
houdan dernier volet à présent de notre
dossier consacré cette semaine aux
compétences du département des yvelines
la collectivité qui travaillent sur
l'insertion professionnelle au travers
d'une agence activity est depuis 2015 la
structure a accompagné plus de 6000
personnes la moitié a retrouvé
aujourd'hui une activité est les
précisions de nicolas d'andry faire une
passe décisive à son futur employeur
dribbler un potentiel collaborateurs
c'est la dernière innovation de l'
agence départementale activity avec ce
match de football entre recruteurs et
demandeurs d'emploi
un événement organisé le 11 février
dernier à guyancourt
pour certaines personnes mais finalement
on est plus en confiance quand on est
sur un terrain de foot que quand on est
enfermé entre quatre murs dans un bureau
à devoir se présente mais d'une façon
hyper formelle prise d'initiative
communication et travaille en équipe le
savoir être des personnes suivies par
activity s'exprime sous l'attention des
dix représentants d'entreprises et
footballeurs pour une soirée on a
rarement l'occasion finalement de
rencontrer plusieurs profils
en une seule fois et bon bah là ça a
commencé par un jeune qui vient de se
présenter à nous d'y rencontrer les
dirigeants de colas donc très sympas ils
sont j'ai pu j'ai pu leur échange et de
trois mois avec eux j'ai essayé de me
présenter au mieux
donc on a moins d'insérer leurs
prothèses bien sûr donc aulas et
l'entreprise aussi à ces structures et
qu'on connaît qui tiennent debout depuis
longtemps ici au siège de l'entreprise
bd comme à elancourt signer traoré 26
ans suit une formation d'habilitation
électrique
cet habitant de la verrière a rejoint
cette pme spécialisée dans l'ingénierie
électrique grâce à activity après une
période d'essai il a été embauché en cdi
dans la boîte ici on fait vraiment du
courant fort courant faible contre l'axé
a vraiment plus diversifiée et font
beaucoup de choses donc j'ai appris en
cours en fonction
c'est en travaillant sans épreuve en
mettant ses enfants plus quand on
travaille en tant que les cours eux
ponctuel motivé
d'abord monteur il est aujourd'hui
techniciens et transmet déjà son savoir
faire à des apprentis et des stagiaires
la jeunesse une priorité pour cette
société
on a une vraie volonté en fait
d'intégrer des jeunes pour leur offrir
de l'emploi
c'est la politique de bd comme le sait
la jeunesse et ce surtout offrir une
chance à des jeunes créés en 2015
activité est un groupement d'intérêt
public créé par le conseil départemental
et la préfecture sept agences
accompagnent les bénéficiaires du rsa
les jeunes entre 18 et 25 ans les
demandeurs d'emploi de longue durée et
les publics des quartiers politique de
la ville cela à travers un réseau
d'entreprises et d'acteurs de l'emploi
et de l'insertion
notre mission première aussi c'est la
remise en activité pour le retour à
l'emploi
mais c'est vraiment de permettre aux
personnes au public d'avoir accès à
une activité qui va les remettre dans
une dynamique pour le retour à l'emploi
on ne pouvait pas se permettre de
regarder monter ses bénéficiaires du rsa
monte le nombre avec des vrais poches de
pauvreté qu'on voyait apparaître sur les
territoires on les a accompagnés
justement avec la création de cette
agence activity qui est une autre façon
de voir l'accompagnement social
puisqu'on est aussi dans
l'accompagnement de la
professionnalisation
une nouvelle manière d'accompagner
l'insertion professionnelle notamment à
travers le sport
d'autres matchs de football devrait être
organisé des olympiades de l'emploi
pourrait même voir le jour fin 2019 un
mot de ce sport et du cyclisme le 77e
paridis s'élancera ce week-end pour la
dixième année consécutive le départ sera
donné depuis les yvelines une première
étape de la course au soleil dimanche à
saint germain en laye avec une boucle de
105 138 km à travers le département
avant de revenir dans la ville et
deuxième étapes depuis lé bréviaire
lundi direction en bellegarde dans le
loiret l lundi soir justement sur tv 78
ne manquez pas une édition spéciale du
7-8 sport consacrée aux paris nice
interviews reportages les cryptages à
retrouver dans cette émission dès 18h30
sur tv 78 une première édition à présent
demain et samedi celle du festivent un
pro junior de rendez vous pour ce
festival international de
l'improvisation théâtrale demain soir à
l'espace philippe noiret aux
clayes-sous-bois et samedi au théâtre
robert manuel a plaisir pour en parler
trois invités manon à sofia edouard
massicotte bonsoir alors vous
participerez vous tous les 2 demain à ce
festival pro junior vous manon avec la
sélection yvelinoise et vous et doit
vous nous mener du québec pour l'équipe
mss l'école mon sens mont saint
sacrement une troisième équipe
francophone sera également de la partie
elle nous vient de belgique c'est la fbi
a illégalement abdelilah chaoui bonsoir
soir vous êtes le président d'impro net
l'association qui organise avec la mjc
des clayes-sous-bois cet événement il
n'existait pour laquelle vous travaillez
également alors le festivent un pro
c'est un événement qui se déroule depuis
18 ans 1 un événement bien intégré
pourquoi le décliner de façon junior
cette année en version junior plusieurs
raisons en fait puisque les juniors nous
demandaient depuis un moment d'organiser
un événement de ce type là et rencontrer
des équipes internationales et on a eu
entre guillemets un concours de
circonstances cette année c'est que en
2001 notre équipe junior avait créé son
premier déplacement au canada au québec
et elle était reçue par le mont saint
sacrement
donc pour le mondial junior à l'époque
et la personne qui nous avait donné
cette possibilité-là denis marchand est
en fin de carrière et se rapproche de la
retraite et on voulait absolument lui
offrir ce cadeau avant qu'ils partent en
retraite donc on a profité des deux
circonstances pour organiser l'événement
donc festive un pro junior qui est une
déclinaison de la version adulte c'est
quoi le principe du festival un pro le
principe du festiva un procès un
festival est une rencontre à la fois
humaine et surtout un prix autour de
l'improvisation théâtrale
donc il n'y a pas de classement c'est
pas un tournoi d'accord le but c'est que
toutes les délégations toutes les
équipes se rencontrent en spectacle
offre le meilleur spectacle qu'ils
puissent proposer au public qui est en
fait des amitiés à la fois artistique et
humaine qui naissent à ce moment là on
le fait depuis 18 ans pour les adultes
et là c'est la première édition pour les
juniors qu'on espère voir renouveler
autant au moins 18 ans gars les trois
équipes pour cette première édition
trois équipes francophones qui viennent
de france de belgique et du québec manon
pour l'équipe yvelinoise quel est votre
état d'esprit à un jour maintenant on
est à la veille de cet événement
je pense qu'on a tous très hâte de
pouvoir enfin commencer à se festif
puisque du coup les québécois sont
arrivés aujourd'hui et a déjà été une
première rencontre et on a vraiment hâte
de se rencontrer autour de l'impro aussi
sur la patinoire demain soir et samedi
soir aussi vous serez à domicile un
honneur pour vous justement d'accueillir
des équipes d'autres pays alors des
équipes francophones pour le coup mais
c'est vraiment incroyable de rencontrer
des équipes qui viennent d'aussi loin
nous notre côté on
on est une une délégation yvelinoise qui
regroupe l'équipe des claies et l'équipe
de plaisir d'accord et qui forme du coup
une seule la délégation pour pour le
match de vendredi et samedi vous edouard
comment vous sentez-vous à un jour vous
venez du québec vous avez traversé
l'atlantique voilà comment vous sentez
vous j'ai vraiment très hâte parce que
ça fait longtemps qu'on attendait ce
moment à l'homme mais après tout le
temps de vol pour en faire des
personnages et le plaisir avec notamment
une gamme sun à l'improvisation
et puis on a vraiment eu sorte dans mon
équipe mais je pense que je sais pas
c'est quoi la grève vous personnellement
ça fait longtemps vous fait de
l'improvisation
bah en fait là ça fait deux ans et demi
avec j'ai commencé à 13
maintenant j'en ai j'en ai 15 et puis là
c'est donc ma troisième saison et
profession au québec
l'improvisation qui a une place
importante en tout cas sur ce territoire
ici à 50 ans on y vit est ce que c'est
le cas aussi au québec au québec oui
tout à fait pratiquement toutes les
écoles ont une équipe des provocations
et yola laisse par exemple qu'elle
allait mener des provocations mais aussi
la relève qui est une ligue qui en fait
à l'université comme pour pour favoriser
le l'improvisation
quant à mon âge prague et et vous
maintenant alors l'improvisation combien
de temps ça fait voilà vous en vous la
pratiquez vous la pratiquez pardon et
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous
moi c'est ma troisième année
d'improvisation du coup j'ai commencé
quand j'étais en seconde et un ami qui
m'a dit viens voir l'impro c'est trop
bien et depuis que j'ai découvert ça et
voilà je suis rendu compte que c'était
quelque chose dont j'avais vraiment
besoin dans mon quotidien
parce que ça me permet de pouvoir lâcher
un maximum de porcs j'ai des tas de
personnages et c'est toujours un plaisir
à jouer avec les copains a joué tous
ensemble à partager tout ça tous
ensemble et une troisième équipe qui
sera également aligné demain c'est la
nba qui nous vient de belgique deux
rendez-vous des lilas oakley et à
plaisir comment vont se dérouler ces
deux soirées ce que ça va être des
soirées similaire au contraire aller
voir un spectacle différent sur
l'organisation ça sera similaire
trois rencontres de 30 minutes en fait
qui vont permettre aux équipes de se
rencontrer sur chaque soir une fois deux
fois sur le festival
comment j'ai dit tout à l'heure il n'y a
pas de classement donc et comme c'est de
l'impro en fait même si le schéma de
chaque soirée le même bain on a deux
spectacles qui vont être proposés chaque
soir avec un contenu différent avec
aussi des arbitres qui vont être
extrêmement important donc dans les
thèmes qui vont proposer aux comédiens
ce qui fera que forcément les
improvisations seront différentes le
concept aussi sur le contenu ceux qui
sont pas initiés à ce concept de
l'improvisation comment ça se déroule un
match d'improvisation quel est le
principe un concept un match ces deux
équipes de six comédiens qui vont se
rencontrer qui vont jouer sur des
improvisations plus ou moins longue qui
vont être proposées par un arbitre donc
qui est là pour donner les contraintes
donc le thème les catégories donc les
genres théâtraux qui va voir qui va
vouloir voir sur scène et
et puis le public un rôle extrêmement
important parce que même s'il n'y a pas
de classement il y aura comme le vote du
public qui va donner un point chaque à
chaque improvisation pour l'une ou
l'autre des équipes
donc voilà trois trois rencontres par
soir avec des catégories des thèmes très
très différents qui vont nous être
proposées par les deux arbitres du
festival et pas de classement encore une
fois le but c'est surtout proposer le
meilleur spectacle possible
eh bien vous souhaite de très belles
soirées merci à vous trois manon
abdelilah est également edwards est
repassé sur ce plateau et ce premier
festival pro junior je rappelle que
c'est demain et samedi aux
clayes-sous-bois ya plaisir toutes les
infos pratiques à retrouver bien sûr sur
le site internet et qui s'affiche en bas
de l'écran en ces vacances d'hiver il
était proposé d'enrichir son vocabulaire
et de perfectionner son accent autour de
fouet de spatules terry molton animé un
atelier l'aide cook in english et
marylène heye à pishin haut et grady là
le norcy ont suivi la préparation de
mets fine
[Musique]
s'attache les cheveux et on enfile le
tablier cet après midi dans ce
restaurant grec de versailles
on va explorer la cuisine américaine en
anglais oui mais c'est pour les enfants
les adultes de faire leur cette
américaine
ils ont une cuisine
donc c'est un nathalie et ludique terim
olten s'est vite rendu compte qu'on
saigne et une longue et des jeunes est
bien plus simple autour d'une activité
c'est ainsi que sont nés ces ateliers
let's cooking lich king réussi un assez
bon chaque étape de la recette est un
prétexte pour enrichir son vocabulaire
répétait les différentes équipes se
répartissent les tâches et selon
créative dans la préparation de leurs me
fit équilibré on doit miser le mélange
convient de faire en fait un mélange de
farine est décrit est en fait on doit le
tamiser et le mettre dans un bol en fait
je crois qu'il doit peser les jambes
erin donc je crois qu'il m'en faut
centigrades
une fois les préparations incorporer
dans leurs moules c'est parti pour dix
huit minutes de cuisson terry et ses
élèves lisent la recette et font le
point sur les nouveaux mots appris
chacun va voir si ma femme pour partager
avec ma famille
ces ateliers ont lieu durant les
vacances scolaires ainsi que les
mercredis et samedis pensez à réserver
les recettes américaines de terry bolton
ou leur succès un autre atelier pas sur
cette fois ci que ça vous donne
l'appétit le thème les bactéries à
champignons ou autres levure ce matin
quinze enfants ont pu découvrir à à
guyancourt le monde des micro-organismes
sur place également au riz les onze ces
petits scientifiques en herbe sont en
train de fabriquer leur propre pain pour
observer par la suite l'effet de la
levure
cet atelier s'inscrit dans le cadre de
la manifestation nationale du goût
organisée par la ville de guyancourt
toutes les sciences dans notre quotidien
et l'idée c'est de donner un regard
scientifique un peu différent par
rapport à aborder cette thématique avec
les enfants de façon ludique et
interactive
pendant une heure et demie ses enfants
âgés de 4 à 10 ans ont pu notamment
analyser différents types de champignons
j'ai appris pas mal de monde champion
aussi j'applique à des champignons qui
transforme des insectes un zombie autre
apprentissage pour ces scientifiques
d'un jour les propriétés de la levure la
levure relâche du gaz
donc ce gaz on va pouvoir l'observer ce
qui va être capturé donc dans un ballon
et donc on va pouvoir voir ce ballon
grossir de plus en plus pour voir
justement que ce sont des êtres vivants
objectifs de l'atelier rendre plus
accessible et ludique cette thématique
des levures et moisissures
chacun a pu apprendre à fabriquer son
pain
[Musique]
petit doute pour meliana et pauline sur
le nombre de cuillères de farine
en revanche du côté du yen et de josiah
on en est déjà à l'étape du pétrissage
on a mis de la farine du sucre
on a aussi mis du du seul chaque enfant
est reparti avec son petit pan et
quelques notions scientifiques en plus
et demain lors d'un nouvel atelier les
enfants pourront découvrir l'importance
du cerveau noter également qu'une
exposition sur la science a du goût se
tient jusqu'au 16 mars à la maison de
quartier à théodore monod pour refermer
ce journal direction elancourt ou une
performance artistique et est au
programme à la commanderie rothko
untitled numéro 2 par claire une grille
de cottenceau et olivier mellano une
création sonore sur le mouvement dans le
cadre de l'exposition mémento corpus de
dan ramène qui se tient en ce moment sur
le site saint quentinois d'inspiration à
trouver dans un poème écouter ses propos
collectées par mélanie poquet c'est un
poème de john taggart c'était le choc le
poème de la chapelle rothko parce
qu'avec can get caught on sort on
travaille autour de recours depuis
quelques années en effet un atelier
création radiophonique pour france
culture il ya deux ans et on poursuit ce
travail
pour un spectacle qui sera monté en 2020
pourquoi ce poème parce qu ils se
rattachent à macro de coups et qu'en
fait il parle il est beaucoup sur la
réception
c'est un poème un donc c'est ça parle
plus de la réception de l'oeuvre plutôt
que un texte didactique donc si on sait
qu'il nous a vraiment intéressé je
trouve que c'est vrai que ce poème la
musique d'olivier et puis les filles
être ici voulait des fonctions de dos
d'âne savoir l'exposition memento corpus
qui se terminera ce dimanche à la
commanderie à elancourt d'autres idées
de sorties à retrouver bien sûr et dans
l'émission 7 8 loisirs présenté par
marylène iapichino c'est dans un instant
c'est la fin de cette édition le 7-8
journal à retrouver sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 très belle soirée à tous
[Musique]